[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
updating the celebrity bracket challenge
john daly yeah that john daly is uh
in first place among the celebrities
seton o'connor and jim parsons are
second
and then our next guest brian cranston
is third
talk to great game leading up to the
bracket challenge and so far
delivering but it uh might be a little
difficult for you to win it with
iowa as your team to win the national
title there brian
hey don't give up on iowa still think
they've got some life
it's not a double elimination by the way
oh great now you
know what was your strategy because you
did talk a great game
going into this i well i always wanted
to pick someone who is not
you know the gonzagas of the world and
you know the easy pick
like some of the rest of those
celebrities you've gotten the
in the game you know and i and uh i just
thought
you know in looking at it over the year
i thought they were playing really
tough basketball and i i thought that
was the team that
could rise to the top but uh boy i was
quickly proven wrong there
what would it mean to win the celebrity
bracket challenge to you
you know if i can be honest for a second
and very sincere dan
i've been very fortunate to win emmys
and golden globes and tony awards
but none of them would match what this
would mean to me
this would be the pinnacle this would go
in my trophy chest uh in the very center
with a with its own light
shining on it and
by the way can i see what the trophy is
can i i haven't seen
what it looks like it's
it's a it's a 1974 tv
console so it's it's got a stereo
in it you can play 45s and it's got a tv
in it
so it's really really pretty i want that
thing more than ever now no i would
i would kill a very close relative
uh we were bringing up as you might
expect on this program in the first hour
we were talking about steven seagal
and his running ability and how
he doesn't run very well but in in your
honor you know
the show you do in new orleans you're
you're running you know part some of the
scenes you're jogging there in the
morning
can you act athletic as an actor
you mean me personally yes like how hard
is that that steven seagal
is a guy who can kill us all and but he
can't run
yeah you just rhymed by the way which
was good
steven's the goal um
uh i you know it is actually difficult
and if i
if i have more of a confession here is
that i didn't do a lot of that running
uh anytime you see the me running oh
yeah look at you looking
depressed and and sad that i lied to you
it's it's tv i thought you weren't no i
thought you were a method actor i
thought that you took
on oh no i mean brando used to run
de niro runs pacino runs
none of those guys run wow
so you're not running in no i'm doing
some of it i'm doing some of it but
okay you know you run you literally run
a risk of injury if if and if i go down
it's not good you know who could take my
place you you kind of look like me in a
in a younger version not as handsome but
younger
i i'm like two months younger than you i
think
yeah so i turned five uh this month
i'm in may yeah yeah so i'm i'm
i am younger than you yeah you are i
could buy
two months yeah so respect your elders
yeah but i i was always wondering about
like tom cruise can run
but it feels like anything right but it
feels like they it
they you know accentuate his ability to
run
have you worked with tom cruise before i
was in the same movie
with tom cruise but we didn't work
together i was in a movie called
uh rock of ages now was that his choice
that you wouldn't be in the same scene
with him
but be it it was his contract that
stipulated that
i i i'll allow him to be in the same
movie but we will
not work together he is amazing
i really like tom he's a he's i think
he's the hardest worker in hollywood and
he's always been really gregarious and
and fun
and and nice uh and no i don't
know if anyone who works harder in his
scenes than tom
let's go over the lazy actors in
hollywood if cruz is
you know a really hard worker can you
name some names of guys who are just
lazy
i can okay
like clooney you know you said clooney
kind of mails it in
well yeah he's you know i have a story
about clooney i
i was i was doing a play i was a in
hollywood this is
20 35 years ago something like that
and i was asked to stay on in the play
as an understudy and i was insulted
because i
felt at that time i earned the role of
this
successful play and they said well we
got uh
we got the two guys who were coming in
and uh
i i said forget it i quit i'm out
and i stormed out of the building and i
just happened to walk by one of the
rooms where they were rehearsing and i
snuck in the back and i watched
george clooney and his and his cousin
miguel farrar
doing the scenes that i was very well
versed in
and they i got to admit they were so
good that i
walked back in tail between my legs to
the artistic director and said okay
[Laughter]
did you ever do an audition where you go
i got this
um a lot of them you want to have that
feeling
of confidence that you did really well
but if you ever get into that mindset of
i've got it counting
you know it's like the it's like the
wide receiver uh
about to do the dance step in the end
zone and he doesn't see the guy come up
behind him and knock the ball
out of his you you're you're in danger
you you should never do that because you
know it's like shooting a three-point
shot
you might have a good target but man
you're not going to make them
all and if you start counting it and
celebrating before you drop it
yeah you're you're going to look foolish
are you using
sports analogy so i'll be able to follow
you
i was trying to help you get a segway
into you know talking about the
tournament and things because i know you
could be kind of slow at times yes yes
yeah very slow
very slow what's your alma mater i
didn't go to college
i didn't i i went to two years at a
junior college and i was about to
transfer i was going to go to ucla
to under a uh administration of justice
uh major but two years into this junior
college i discovered girls and acting
classes
and all of a sudden everything went out
the window
i mean it up ended the the apple cart i
i all of a sudden i i from being so sure
of what i wanted to do
to completely confused and so i left
school and
traveled around for a few years and then
uh then got into the acting business
when are you shooting season two of your
honor
no there is no season two uh we did the
one year
wait you know that they would like to
continue on with the season two but
right now there is no there are no plans
to
continue um it is what it is how can i
help how can i help brian i thought it
was
a great show oh thank you i thought it
was great
uh you know with the exception of the of
the running parts i think
yeah now that i know that you weren't
doing them
but you know there was a cliffhanger at
the very end there brian
well i don't know about a cliffhanger it
was a tragic ending
well you did you didn't watch it did you
i did
can i it's spoiler alert where your son
is
in your arms at the very end
let's just leave it at that yeah and
then there's the mob guy
and then your son is dating his daughter
and
he's just realizing that okay good watch
i'm i'm
i'm touched by that i i was very
impressed i i really enjoyed it i
thought it was great and i love that it
was spaced out i had to watch
each week yes i think that that's old
school that's what we grew up with and i
like that
i had to wait for the next week for the
episode
it's kind of like you know not
downloading your show we have to wait
till the next morning
to catch you know your next show yeah we
you know we can't uh just you know
stuff ourselves with dan patrick uh all
day long
and and fill up you know you gotta you
gotta pace yourself and i've been called
your honor before
with what i do here because this is sort
of my
courtroom this is what i do but i'm not
somebody who can be
bought or manipulated like your
character could have been
you know when i would have loved to have
seen a cutaway shot of the danettes
when you said i've been called your
honor over here and just to see them
lower their heads or suppress a smile no
no they know this this is this
court is in session here brian why
my i'll tell you yeah yeah see now i
return the favor of being a little smack
talk and cocky like you were how's it
feel there
huh he's the smack talking cocky
or something like that uh are you doing
anything the rest of the day
like is this it this is the highlight of
my day dan this is this is all i'm doing
the earliest you've started drinking
is when during the pandemic uh well
you know that aaron paul and i have the
mezcal dos hombres yes
and uh so a lot of times we'll go on
these zoom calls with
sales forces around the country and
they're starting theirs at 11 o'clock in
the morning their sales group meeting
on the east coast we're on the west
coast and so it's eight o'clock in the
morning here and they're going come on
share a drink with us everyone's like oh
my god
so we're sipping a little dos umbres at
eight o'clock in the morning sometimes
but do you have you ever had something
real to drink during a scene
where you're drinking a drinking scene
no
no no no that's is that frowned upon
well it's just you know people think a
lot of
people who drink think that they're
smarter sharper
funnier when they drink and
you know they really aren't they really
aren't
and uh you know i've never seen you
drunk
um are you a happy drunk
well what do you mean like do i hug am i
feeling like a touchy
yeah touchy feely cry kind of guy
no i'm that way without drinking oh but
i no i don't know we we would get along
well we had shots
or drinks backstage on broadway yeah
but those were just little ones like
yeah you kind of cut me off there after
i think
one or two well i didn't want you to be
sloppy and you know and
stumble home billy bob thornton said in
bad santa
he actually got drunk in in one of the
scenes
yeah i can i can imagine but but now
when i
when i look back on the scene i think
he's falling down in the escalator and
then you realize
he's actually he said he was hammered
[Laughter]
wow have you worked with billy bomb i
have not
okay no no well is he in the tournament
billy is not in the in the term michael
douglas is
is he yeah how's he doing michael
douglas
uh let me see how michael's doing uh
will ferrell's in here
uh michael douglas is uh tied for 22nd
okay uh i'm trying to think if there's
any um adam sandler
is uh in here he's doing well okay
actor uh i'm in third place right now
yeah but you won't
last there okay just
you know just give me this straight dope
here i i've got i've got
of course the gonzagas and the baylors
i've got houston
and michigan all in my elite eight so
i've got four of the eight
that's pretty good and then it goes
south after that i think that goes
real well that's why we wanted to have
you on today because
nobody was gonna care tomorrow
i i mean i had jim parsons on last week
when he was in first place so
you know how quickly we move on here
okay so
who's got what who how many uh players
there
have uh have the you know no one picked
sc and ucla had been the elite
i think will ferrell did because he went
to usc he went to sc
yeah good for him man and by the way i
think
you watch out sc can upend gonzaga
today you watch that it it might happen
well that's not going out on a limb what
do you mean it's not going out a limb
gonzaga is undefeated what are you
talking about of course they have a
chance
i'm not the chance i mean a good chance
what's that mean
like you're not calling and you're not
putting something on the line
would you do like uh a pie in the face
would you do a pie to the face
if you if usc doesn't win then you take
a pie to the face like your wife comes
in and does a pie to the face
if usc beats gonzaga i will take a pie
to the face
you got it let's pie to the face pinkie
swear pinky swear there's my pinky's
right there okay
pie to the face of the face pinky swear
yeah all right uh i hope you have a
season two of your honor you did a great
job with that
really liked it and uh if not then you
know it's just another
thing that you do discard it and you
move on to something else and you'll be
brilliant in that as well
oh thanks must be such a burden must be
such just good
man hope everything's well
it's always good always good to talk to
you brian and uh thanks for joining us
you bet thanks that's uh the uh smack
talking brian cranston on the show